Levon uh yesterday's match didn't go
your way but still it feels like you're
always enjoying yourself whenever you
play this rapid faster time controls
especially this particular moment I want
to drag your attention to when you
decide to sacrifice The Exchange quite
easily quickly
yeah I'm honestly enjoying playing chess
a lot lately so it's a
I mean it's type of a thing that you
really want to do when you're getting
such a bishop running before
it's difficult to explain for non-chess
players but it's one of those feelings
that you know you feel the Harmony and
everything is just going your way and
that that kind of worked for me would
you say this was the critical moment in
this particular match
not so sure I think there are many
critical moments let's keep going later
I think I I misplayed it of course I I
saw Rook F6 I should have played Rook F6
yeah five yes I actually blundered this
idea with H4 which is uh very very good
very fast played in the game yeah yeah
great idea and then I thought okay let's
just play safe and here after G3 I
thought black has enough counter play I
was thinking that I'm still better after
D4
but it's just in in this in this uh time
format it's so much easier to play with
white because the wicking yeah in the
worst case scenario I always have this
C4 Bishop to C3 and impactuals yeah yeah
lots of perpetuals yeah you're never
going to be in danger to actually lose
this position which is but after H3 uh
which was I thought uh a positional
mistake things are very easy yeah Bishop
to G3 now finally your Bishop found a
very safe and defensive uh placement as
well as well as offensive because you
played before you get a lot of pressure
in the center like this you're feeling
pretty comfortable at this point yeah I
think this was the critical moment
actually this H3 H3 was the big mistake
yeah yeah yeah and after that you
execute it quite nicely but I have to
say
the second match the second game was not
easy at all right yeah I think I mixed
up some moves I think on the eighth move
I'm supposed to play H6 before D5 the 45
H6 and what is the difference
well it's kind of a Tempo yeah I think
yes here Sydney Bishop D5 Knight F3 97
uh
yeah 95 I think this is so much much
better version than what I've got also
there is this G5 here I think which is
also totally fine for black yes and only
after he played 95 I realized so maybe I
forgot to play six without this and now
if you play H6 the problem is Knight to
D7 is coming and that's just a very bad
situation after that okay so I kind of
had to go to this end game which
of course it's not very enjoyable to
play at least there's a b plan right
at least there's a B flat Bishop to E7
you are defending against the two
Bishops but you found this exchange
sacrifice I have to do it you have to do
it yeah yeah
and did you feel like he was fighting on
the pressure did you feel him oh yeah it
was comfortable like this one but but
you know it's also a type of a position
that is not so easy to play with white
because
is a must win situation
yeah you you have to really pay
attention
pay attention not too loud like to get a
fortress
and it didn't seem like at any point he
got like any sort of
but here he was he was doing very well
yes H5 yeah
yeah rukish one was not the move yeah I
thought the bishop H4 I also thought
about this
and then kind of Rook G7 and undermining
because the F7 Pawn
I think Sam forgot that I have this
counter play with Rook V8
after Rook to G7 Rook to d8 and our
Knight goes back to C5 yeah D3 one zero
interest and that makes a lot of sense
and he had to defend with Rook to D1 but
that allows it yeah I'm not sure what
happened later but it seemed that I I
was always in control someone else yes
yes except at this point we're actually
forgot
that he can just read through the bishop
oh it doesn't seem like he did have this
move yeah yeah here I was a bit worried
yeah I hear it was a bit worried and the
idea being that he just wants to push
the pawn E6 Bishop to D6 but yeah I
think after so after uh where did I make
the mistake on move number 41 or
um King to A4 was the mistake you had to
play Knight to B4 yeah I thought about
this yeah night before I was I was
actually afraid of some rookie eight
982 and you know kind of take and then
E6 yeah and this is winning ah but uh
after okay they don't have to uh I can
just create a kind of flavor so F7 and
Rook F3 yeah you have to yeah this is
this I somehow didn't believe so much
and because I was already it's gonna
become a race are you getting to this
king or is he promoting his Pawn right
yeah I was a bit scared that he'll give
this check Rook C8 you know it's a rook
F7 check can get for Rook C8 yeah
and the only movies it's not easy I mean
only a few seconds on the clock that's
pretty much impossible it can be five
with Knight C6 ideas definitely I mean
it's easy to see but it's not easy to
assess yeah yeah yeah but still not easy
for him to finish the game either and
find the best precise move to get the
advantage which he didn't you managed to
equalize Levon congratulations so uh
tomorrow you have a rest day what are
you going to do are you going to enjoy
it spend it with your family what are
you going to do well it's a
well-deserved dressed after my
yesterday's display
uh I mean in the rapid section of course
uh
I think uh I'll I'll just go to the park
probably you know apparently the weather
is going to get better because it's
super freezing last couple of days yeah
so this this is what I can do go and
have a little exercise get some sunshine
get some vitamin D guys any questions
quick question for you
um uh Lavon who who is your future
opponent
um what I think
probably whoever loses between Hikaru
and Dominguez the system is so
complicated I don't even know who I'm
playing
uh because I was just I was just curious
if you would play linear a rematch
potentially it does seem to be the case
yes that you could potentially player
loses but which is no linear right now
is most likely going to be a draw so
there is yeah but I'm just saying that
there was that possibility that uh that
was what I said so I don't get to play
more rapid what's going on oh yeah yeah
oh my God this is so beautiful
so happy
very nice okay good luck and enjoy the
cold weather brisk yes weather yes and
let's check out where Lavon actually
stands and